de simone veil à l'historien pierre
vidal-naquet de la ligue des droits de
l'homme au ministre chargé de
l'enseignement supérieur monsieur alain
devaquet tous se déclarent indignés par
cette thèse d'henri rock des enseignants
de nantes dénonce le fait que le label
de l'université a été attribué à un tel
ouvrage en rock n'est pas le premier
dans son genre
rappelez-vous sept autres universitaires
robert faurisson il y a 6 ans à lyon
contestant également les chambres à gaz
hervé brusini pas vraiment courageux les
amis de monsieur roch quand ils se
réunissent et dans la clandestinité mais
regardez dans cet hôtel il y a deux ans
ils étaient tous là et notre cameraman
frédéric vasseur a réussi ce qu'ils
craignent le plus il filme la en secret
et pour la première fois les visages de
ceux qui réécrivent l'histoire les
blanchisseurs du nazisme
il fit une cette réunion de
révisionniste racistes et antisémites
en costume bleu à gauche en arrière-plan
le professeur robert faurisson avec ses
amies également au fond complètement au
fond le père franck lui n'est soupçonné
que d'être un faux prêtre virale un chef
du clan et finalement la première et
unique image du fondateur et financier
de cet institut willis carto tous ces
gens qui nient ainsi l'évidence qu'elle
est finalement leur but les
révisionnistes malgré leurs prétentions
ne sont pas des historiens
ce qui les intéresse ce n'est pas de
comprendre l'histoire c'est d'en effacer
d'en retrancher le génocide des juifs
pour certains nostalgiques du nazisme
il s'agit tout simplement de réhabiliter
hitler pour d'autres il s'agit de priver
l'état d'israël de toute légitimité
ce qu'ils appellent les sionistes on
distille inventé la légende de
l'extermination pour justifier
l'existence de l'état d'israël et pour
extorquer à la fois la sympathique et
les capitaux de l'occident mais ce qui
me paraît particulièrement grave dans
cette affaire c'est que pour la première
fois un tel discours reçoit droit de
cité dans l'université française
voici tout d'un coup cette monstruosité
érigé en thèse en recherche
or qu'est-ce que c'est que l'université
c'est le lieu de la transmission et de
l'élaboration des savoirs c'est le lieu
où doit régner la morale de la vérité